just to return briefly back to aoc and
bernie sanders what are your thoughts
about these modern political figures
that represent some of these ideas and
they sometimes refer to those ideas as
democratic socialism right
the crucial thing about bernie and about
aoc and it's particularly true about
bernie
uh because aoc is much younger and
bernie's an older man
um
bernie
being roughly my age
um has been around
formatively as a student as an activist
and then coming up through the ranks in
in burlington vermont as a mayor and all
the rest
um
he lived through what for lack of a
better term i would call cold war
america and the taboo in cold war
america running from around 1945 six
to the present i mean really never
stopped
um
was a
manichaean
world view the united states is good it
defines democracy and the soviet union
is awful it defines whatever the
opposite of democracy
should be called um good here evil there
it was taken so far
that even in among the ranks of
academic individuals
it was impossible
to talk have a conversation i mean
i can't tell just make it very personal
the number of times i would raise my
hand in my classes at harvard or
stanford or yale
and i would ask a question that had
something to do with marxism because i
was studying it on my own there were
there were no courses that teach this to
me except by people who trash that you
know that other than that and i didn't
want that um
so i would ask a question
and i would see in the faces of my
teachers
both those i didn't much care for and
those who were good teachers that i
liked
fear it was just fear they didn't want
to go there they didn't want to answer
my question and i after a while i got to
know some of them and i found out why
because you don't know how the rest of
the class is going to understand this
either they would have to say i don't
know which would be the honest truth
from any of them but a professor does
not want to say in a classroom i don't
know this is not cool
or they'd have to if they knew
they'd have to say something
that indicated they didn't know really
much and they weren't even to do that or
they would know something
and maybe that would be because
they were interested
they did not want the rest of the
students to begin to say oh you know
professor smith um well you know he's
interested in
this is not good for your career you
don't know how this is going to play out
who's going to say what to whom
and i could see in their faces what i
later learned because they told me don't
come to my office hours you we're in the
office we can talk about it but i'm
that's how bad it was
is is it not still pretty much
in my field the great so-called debate
i mean i find it boring but the great
debate for my colleagues
is between what's called neo-classical
economics and keynesian economics
neoclassical the government should stay
out of the economy
let's say fair or old liberalism and the
keynesians saying no you you crazy
neo-classical if you do that you'll have
great depressions and the system will
collapse you need the government to come
in to solve the problems to fix the
weaknesses
and they hate each other and they throw
each other out of their jobs
one of the very few things they can do
together that they agree on is keeping
people like me out
that they can find common ground uh to
do so i had to learn it all on myself
why am i telling you this because
this taboo
means that all of the complicated
developments within
marxism and within socialism
of the post-world war ii period the vast
bulk of all of that is unknown
not just to the average american person
but to the average american academic to
the average american who thinks of
himself or herself as an intellectual i
mean i i have had to spend ridiculous
amounts of my time
explaining soviet history i have no idea
or
saying there's this man lukach a
hungarian marxist he really had
interested
or to explain that gramsci was not a
great literary critic he was head of the
communist party of italy for most of his
adult life
what does that mean why you like gramsci
as a literary critic but um uh they were
and they didn't even know they don't
even know it's been erased
it's a little bit like stories i've
heard about trotsky and his influence
kind of erased in the soviet union
because he obviously fell out of favor
and so somehow all of his writings many
of which are very interesting and
complicated uh anyway so
what you're going to have in this
country is a slow
awakening of socialism
from a long hibernation called the cold
war
i never expected to be very honest with
you that i would live to see i knew it
would come
because these things always do
but i didn't expect to see it so i have
been surprised
as have a lot of us that when it starts
to happen it happens fast
so the uh you see bernie is an early
sign of the the awakening absolutely
from the cold war to to
accept the action was
we all knew and everybody who paid
attention he didn't hide it
but 2016 he go he makes a decision
momentous to run for president he's just
a senator from vermont vermont is one of
the smallest states in the union
people who live in vermont love to tell
you that there are more cows than people
in vermont etc etc
uh so here from this little state this
elderly gentleman with a new york city
accent
runs for or and says i'm a socialist and
when they attack him he doesn't run away
i'm a socialist i'm a socialist now he
had been it wasn't that it wasn't the
secret that suddenly got out
but the great question and i don't mind
telling you because i went to the right
schools
i know a lot of people you know you know
janet yellen was my classmate at yale
and stuff like that so
i was speaking with a high official of
the democratic party and i said well
what do you think about bernie uh
entering the race
makes no difference they get one percent
of the vote
right he was wrong they had no idea what
was coming but the truth is i didn't
either it wasn't just that he didn't get
it i thought his one percent was
probably right so we were both wrong
yeah change can happen fast do you think
aoc might be president one day yeah
possible possible and but two things
number one
it's fast
number two
it's going to go in the following
direction i would guess
you begin
with the most
moderate
calm
non-confrontational socialism you can
imagine so not aoc or bernie
no no they are not confrontational in my
judgment in terms of the ideas of
socialism i mean they're both very
feisty they're feisty personally but not
but not ideologically
you know she is
bernie is also
you know in in honest moments and they
both really are pretty honest folks at
least in my experience
um
in honest moments bernie will tell you
that his what he advocates as democratic
socialism is pretty much what fdr was in
the 1930s
it was a kind of popular
government
tax the rich a lot more than you do now
to provide a lot more support for the
working class than you do now that's not
a fundamental change that's what he
means by socialism when he talks about
it and he's asked for examples he
mentions denmark a lot okay that that
that's consistent that that's the
softest kind of socialism and that's
where we're going to start in a country
coming out of hibernation
pretty soon it's already happening
there'll be people who need and want to
go further in the direction of socialism
than bernie and aoc are comfortable with
you could already see that the shoots of
it now you know aoc voted
together with most of the others to
support the money for ukraine
okay that a lot of people in the in the
socialist movement do not support that
uh and that's gonna i don't know exactly
how that's gonna work out but
that should give people an idea there
are disagreements and they're gonna
fester
so people in the socialist sphere don't
support money from the united states in
the large amounts that it is being sent
to ukraine is it because of it's a
fundamentally the military-industrial
complex is a capitalist institution kind
of thing
no i wonder what does i mean there's
some people for whom that's the issue
then there are people for whom
this is you know it's guns and butter
and why are we
why are we over there when we have such
needs at home that are being neglected
yeah and then there are people who
well go back to what we talked about the
beginning who are more like lenin and
debs
this is this is a fight between
western capitalism and russian
oligarchs and
and wannabe oligarchs in ukraine and
what are we doing here
we have to insist that these
forces
sit down at the bargaining table and
negotiate a settlement don't kill large
numbers of ukraine i mean everybody's
willing to fight to the last ukrainian
is a little strange here what are you
doing
you're supposed to be in favor of peace
you know and for the united states which
just finished
invading and occupying afghanistan and
iraq to be against another country
invading i mean who in the world is
going to take this seriously this is
crazy that you know i invade it's good
and you invade is terrible
what
you know what are you doing what why are
you doing that what what what's what's
going on here all of these questions are
being active by the way not just by
socialists by lots of other people too
inside the democratic party and also
inside the republican party
you watch that tucker carlson or people
like that they are against the stuff in
in ukraine they don't want the money
spent there they don't want the weapons
sent there they don't like the whole
policy it's
and trump wobble so
mr biden's policy has got all kinds of
critics on the left and the right and
every day that this thing lasts these
criticisms get bigger anyway the point
is that aoc
and
bernie
should be i think evaluated as the early
shoots
after a long winter of cold war
uh
isolation from the whole
you know when i explained to people the
the the contribution made for example to
modern marxism i'll give you an example
by the the french philosopher luis
altucere i don't know if the name means
anything to you okay
he was the rector of the ecole normale
superior in paris that's the equivalent
imagine in this country if there were a
university that combined harvard yale
princeton and mit i mean it would be the
university well the ecole normale in
france in paris is the
he was a tenured professor who became
the rector director is like the
president of the university an active
member of the french communist party
most of his adult life
that was possible in france during the
cold war that was unthinkable in this
country you could not in a million years
right
so
i
altoser as a philosopher
tried to bring a version of
postmodernism
into marxism with enormous
impact all over the world where he
traveled
not just in europe all over all right so
if you want to look him up i'll spell it
out for you sure
a-l-t-h-u-s-s-e-r
luis the louis l-o-u-i-s luis altucere
look him up you'll see tons of stuff by
the way mit press is a major publisher
if i remember of his works in english
by the way the textbook i wrote in
economics in case you're ever interested
was also published by the mit press and
the title
of the contending economic theories
neoclassical keynesian and marxian
that's an mri marxian yeah that's right
and by the way when we think uh
i don't know if there's an interesting
distinction between marxian economics
and marxist
that's the mark i suppose marxism is the
umbrella yeah of everything that i only
use it because marxist i use as a noun a
person is a marxist marxian i use as an
adjective to qualify but other i don't
mean some great different there's a last
point i would like to make about aoc and
bernie that's also general
i'm a historian too
and i know
that the transition out of feudalism in
europe to capitalism
was a transition that took centuries and
that occurred in fits and starts so for
example
a feudal manner would start to
disintegrate surfs would run away they'd
run into a town
how would they live in the town they had
no land anymore because they had run
away from the feudal manner
a deal was struck without the people
involved in the deal understanding what
they were doing
a merchant
would say to one of these serfs
i'm in the business of buying and then
reselling stuff and living off the
difference
but you know i could make more money if
i produce some of this stuff myself
rather than buy it from somebody else so
i'm gonna i'm gonna make you a deal i'm
gonna give you money once a week i'll
give you a money what we would later
call a wage and you come here and under
my supervision you make this crap that
i'm gonna then sell
and this all works out in other words
there were there were
efforts unconscious
not self-aware
to go out of feudalism to a new system
some of them lasted a few days and then
fell apart
some of them lasted weeks or months or
years
but it took a long time
before
the conditions were ready
for a kind of a general switch
and once that was done it grew on itself
and became the global capitalist system
we have today that's the only model we
have
so for me
that's what i see when i look at
socialism i see the paris commune was an
event an attempt
it lasted a few weeks
i see russia that was an attempt lasted
70 years
then i say you know fill in the blank i
see these are all early experiments
these are all you learn things to do
learn things never to do again the good
the bad
what do you build on how do you learn
and that's what the socialist and
marxist tradition when it's serious
that's what it does so in your ideas
sort of capitalism was a significant
improvement over the feudalism yes uh
and
we are coming to an age and over slavery
and we're coming to an age where
capitalism will die out and make it's
it's not that kaepernick is somehow
fundamentally broken
it's better than the things that came
before it but there is going to be
things yet better and they will be
grounded in the ideas of marxism and
socialism
you